So, this afternoon we
have a great treat.
We're going to be joined
by President Salovey.
This is our third year of the
Day of Data and each year we
strive to get a senior
administrator to come and talk
to us and this year
we struck it big.
We got the university President.
He has pushed aside the provost
this year, but Ben was okay
with it, and then we'll be
hearing from President Salovey.
He has a long career here
at Yale where he started as a
graduate student and was a
professor of psychology, and
through all of that work,
himself has worked with data
a lot, so this is both important
to Yale as a whole, but also to
his own personal research.
So, let me introduce
President Salovey.
(Applause)
Well, thank you very much,
Susan, and welcome everybody.
You know, I just want to
say something about Susan.
When we hired a university
librarian a few years back we
were looking for someone who
would interpret what it means to
be the university librarian
in the broadest possible way.
You know, not just a custodian
of book collections, but a kind
of recognition that the
contemporary university
librarian is someone who really
facilitates research scholarship
in teaching by essentially
making resources of all kinds
that can be archive collected,
organized, interpreted available
to them, and Susan has
interpreted that charge, that
mission, that job description as
broadly as anyone on this campus
and we are very, very fortunate
to have her in that role.
It's wonderful to have someone
who respects the old and the
traditional and loves books, but
also is not afraid to embrace
and rush toward the new, the
entire technological end of all
of this and she does
both very, very well.
If you really haven't ever
gotten to know her, you should.
Take a minute and introduce
yourselves and find out what's
going on in our library system.
So, it's a pleasure to be here.
This is the third year of an
outstanding program that has
proven quite popular
on this campus.
I think it is a testimonial to
both what libraries do and what
librarians do, but it also
helps to galvanize a kind of
collective interest in the use
of data in research and data
management as well
throughout the campus.
What I love about the theme
is it's so cross cutting and so
interdisciplinary, so, as you
heard, I'm a psychologist,
I work in a data
intensive field.
Most of our data are either
gathered in experiments or in
big field studies or sometimes
in survey research and sometimes
use of archival sources, mostly
quantitative and that's only
just a little tip of the iceberg
of what is possible, but very
dependent, as a psychologist,
both on what capacities the
university had to manage data,
make it available, but also
data analysis interpretation.
And what I love about this
theme, The Day of Data theme,
is it really cuts across
disciplines like my own and sort
of says what are common
ways of managing, planning,
using, interpreting data.
I think many of you know, when I
became president two years ago,
I talked a lot about a more
unified Yale and, in fact,
the theme of the inauguration,
which was two years ago
next month, was going
to be One Yale.
And a couple of weeks before we
were going to announce the theme
One Yale, Harvard announced
their fundraising campaign...
One Harvard.
[Laughter]
And so, we realized that we
had to do One Yale implicitly,
and so, you may have remembered
posters and tote bags and
things that would say Many
Disciplines, Many People,
Many Nationalities, Many
Departments, many this,
many that, many this,
many that... Yale.
Right?
It was one Yale - it was
the implicit One Yale.
Well, you know, when it comes to
thinking about data, numerical,
geographical, textual, visual,
I think we are one Yale.
I think we can take a kind of
unified approach to management,
organization, accessibility,
consultation... all the tools
and assistance that anyone in
this room and beyond might need
and, as a result, do it in a
way that makes this among the
easier places to
actually get work done.
You know, you just have to
look around a little bit at
university initiatives of the
last year to see the ways in
which research data can be used
to address complicated needs of
this place, so, you know, the
opening... I make it sound like
it was yesterday, it wasn't
yesterday... but the opening of
the Center for Science and
Social Science Information was
created three years ago
explicitly to support data
management and analysis in
what had originally been a
wonderful home for
largely biology books.
The Yale Center for Research and
Computing which is supporting
advanced computing, data
processing technology makes its
resources available throughout
the research community.
The university library's
Interdisciplinary Digital
Humanities Lab provides
expertise, equipment, facilities
to faculty and students often
in fields who didn't think of
themselves as data intensive
fields but now discover what
they can do with data.
There's a data policy committee
appointed by the provost and
charged with developing
guidelines for acquisition,
management, storage and
they're going to release their
recommendations
later this semester.
So... I'm hoping that the
Day of Data - my guess is the
Day of Data has something
in it for everyone.
I hope it stimulates you
to think about new ideas,
new approaches to information,
new opportunities, maybe new
supports and services
that Yale provides that you
didn't know about.
If that happens, that would be
a great thing because we want
nothing more than the ability
for you to produce world class
scholarship and research and
then to teach, to provide the
best teaching, I always say the
most excellent teaching but that
sounds like - what are
those characters who have
the excellent adventure?
Bill and Ted?
Bill and Ted.
It sounds like Bill and Ted
when I say and provide the most
excellent education in a
research university environment.
This is part of how we do that.
I don't want to take more time
but because it does give me
great pleasure to introduce
our keynote speaker today.
This is Chaitan Baru.
He's from the University
of California, San Diego.
He currently serves as the
National Science Foundation
Senior Advisor for Data Science.
In that role at NSF, he supports
collaborative efforts pertaining
to big data and he's going
to speak today on the topic of
Data Science R&D:
Current Activities
and Future Directions.
So, let me ask you to join me
in welcoming Chaitan Baru with
a very warm round of applause.
Thanks.
(Applause)
Just a second as
I get this fired up.
Well, thanks very much for
that introduction and actually,
thanks to the organizers
for inviting me here to
give this talk.
It's a real pleasure.
What I've heard so far in
the session, in the morning,
I think there's a lot of
excitement across campus in the
area of data.
This is your third
year to do this.
My sense is each year
this has been building up.
It must be because there's
so much going on right now that
I can see.
So, this is my first visit
to Yale in this capacity.
I think I've been here once
maybe 15 years ago as a tourist,
just touring New England,
happened to go
through New Haven.
But I took the train up
from Washington, D.C.
...it's actually a
very nice train ride.
You see some scenic
spots along the way.
So, very happy to be here.
I think my task in this next
hour using the clock that
actually works as Bob found out,
is A) not to put you to sleep
right after a nice Panera
sandwich; and B) to just give
you sort of, let's say, 25,000
to 30,000-foot level view of the
variety of data science, big
data activities that are going
on, mostly at NSF and I
love to say a little bit of
the interagency things.
So, hopefully, you'll get a
sense of the landscape of things
that are happening.
Needless to say, this is a
really exciting times for data.
We'll get into some of these
during my presentation.
As everyone says, there's
nothing new about data,
especially scientists will say
that's what we've been doing all
along, so we'll touch a little
bit upon what makes it new
and different now.
The reason I actually decided
to leave San Diego and
go to Washington, D.C. and
take this - this is actually a
new position at NSF,
Senior Advisor for Data Science,
and I thought this is a really
interesting time to be there,
both to help NSF think
through some of these plans
and do some of those
interagency things.
So...
All right, so,
let's get started.
So, I purposely used data
science R&D in my title.
It doesn't say big data
and I'll come to that.
The presentation will primarily
be, of course, from the point of
view of NSF.
So, NSF's perspective and role
in the federal government is,
you know, it's the agency that
supports basic curiosity doing
research and these are the words
from the actual mission of NSF:
to promote the progress of
science; to advance the national
health, prosperity, and welfare;
to secure the national defense.
Actually, after I went to NSF I
went over Bush's original report
that put NSF together and, in
fact, what is now filed in that
all was in one organization
and then things split later on.
So, let's get into
the topic right away.
This whole phenomena of big
data, which I don't have to
define, you already heard that
from Bob this morning, I think
fundamentally what it has done,
why are things different now
considering that scientists have
always dealt with data is just
the amount of data and our
ability to so easily collect so
many different types of data for
any problem that we are looking
at has essentially forced on
us greater awareness of data.
It's no longer taking some data
set that you collect or somebody
else, in fact, primarily
that you collected and did
something with it.
Increasingly there are data sets
that others have collected,
increasingly there are
requirements, some of which
might come from the
federal government.
Let's say you have to make this
data available for a long term,
and so, you start worrying
about what does that mean.
Meta data, context,
sustainability, etcetera.
So, the way I would say this is
there's just greater awareness
of all aspects of data.
And this goes, by the way, not
just in science but in business.
As you know, the term really
sort of got adopted by folks in
business and Strata Hadoop
conferences later this month...
I think Bob mentioned it.
I'm actually planning to attend.
I hope some of
you will be there.
It's really a totally energetic
and exciting place to be.
If you just want to see the
extent of stuff that's happening
in industry, Strata Hadoop
conference is a good
place to be.
So, while there is in industry
or in science, we've sort of
thought about traditionally
it's been about just looking at
cleaned up, structured data
and doing the analytics.
Now, we realize that, as we get
not just designed data, but what
is called found data, so not
just data that you created but
maybe that others have put
together and you're using it in
some way in your analysis, you
realize that you worry about the
entire life cycle of data.
You have to have much more
awareness of what is the context
in which this data was
collected, what is the context
in which I'm reusing it.
It's all types of data,
it's unstructured,
some is structured.
We heard about text
analysis this morning.
There's all sorts of image
data that we collect.
There's maps... spatial,
temporal... all of that, and as
context becomes important and
reuse becomes important it's as
much about the meta data so that
there is some understanding of
what this original data set was
as it is about the data itself.
And at the end of the day,
all of this has to be processed
efficiently and used.
So, if you collect data an
you never use it, it's like not
collecting data at all, right?
And also, if you look at in
business, and increasingly in
some of the sciences that are
collecting lots of data...
actually astronomy comes to
mind, but increasingly I would
think things like genomics,
etcetera, there is this issue
of timely use.
I think we are pushing more and
more and more towards real time
online analysis of data.
If you think of it, that's
actually one way by which you
can avoid collecting a whole lot
of data if you can just process
it in time and make use of it or
not and check it or maybe just
keep a representation of it.
So, essentially, as was
mentioned, I'm originally from
the University of California in
San Diego at the Super Computer
Center, but my background
is as a computer scientist.
I'm in the field
called database systems.
So, if you are in the data
field, these are absolutely
exciting times because all the
stuff that you did 10-15 years
ago is all coming back, and
in even more important ways.
So, that's definitely
rejuvenated and created a new
research agenda around data.
Actually, there was a
question I wanted to ask,
so let me do it now.
It's one of those strategies
to make sure that you're
not totally asleep.
So, let's see, how many
folks in the audience
are faculty members?
Okay.
That's good.
There are some, but there's lots
of non faculty, so I assume
a lot of them are grad students,
maybe some are staff.
How many in the audience
are computer scientists?
Right.
So, I think there needs to
be more computer scientists
in the room, but that's
one of the things I will
talk about, data science.
In fact, here it is.
So, if you look at NSF, the
kinds of things that NSF funds,
it stretches the whole range
from basic research on one side
and infrastructure
on the other side.
Now, the infrastructure that NSF
funds, of course, is in support
of basic research, so usually
it's an instrument of some type,
you know, regardless of
which directory that you're in,
whether it's geosciences or
astronomy or ecology, etcetera,
these are all about building
state of the art instruments
that can collect more data
and, of course, that's what
they're all doing.
NSF has programs across the
spectrum, basically search,
as well as applied areas, there
are programs for, for example,
creating software that could be
used by a discipline and maybe
re-used by others.
There are programs
for networking.
There are programs for actually
having super computers and
storage and there are
big programs in many
of the directorates.
I don't think computer science
particularly doesn't have any,
but many of the other
directorates have programs
for data archives.
These are community scientific
data archives, ICPS already was
mentioned, and there
are many others.
And there is, of course, a
division at NSF called the ACI,
which is part of CISE that funds
things on the infrastructure
side and education and
training is also a big part
of all of this, right?
So, there's education and
training, both on the basic side
and the infrastructure side,
that is, there are programs all
the way from doing research in
education to supporting graduate
education, the NRT program
that's there, which used to be
the IGERT, but there
are also programs more on
the training side.
So, if you are a scientist, you
want to use some computational
resources, increasingly I hope
there are also such things
for data resources.
Then there are programs that
allow for training in that area.
So, this whole field of big data
and now introduced data science
sits across all of that.
There are activities at NSF that
are in that box, or that circle,
that cut across from basic
research to infrastructure to
education and training.
I'll say a little
bit about that.
What has this done then, data
science, and actually it's in
the title of the position I
have: I'm the senior advisor
for data science.
And one way I like to think
about it, and maybe it's partly
because I'm also from a super
computer center, is, you know,
big data is to data science
as supercomputing was
to computational science.
In other words, I think there
was a reference earlier that
more is something different.
Right?
So, when you have more of
something, significantly more of
something, you really enter a
new state and that's basically
what supercomputing did.
When you had that scale
of computing available you
had all sorts of new
computational methods in all
sorts of disciplines.
It's not just physics and
astronomy, it's everything all
the way down to social sciences
now, and certainly ecology and
all of those areas looking at
computational techniques to the
extent that we said, okay,
that's a discipline in which
some training needs to be given
and there are several, at least
graduate student programs, in
computational science that get
you trained in how to
model things that are using
computational science and
then how to do them at scale.
This term wasn't mentioned
today, but you may have heard
of this notion of the
Fourth Paradigm, right?
So, the third paradigm is
computing, the fourth paradigm
is data, so computational
science was the third paradigm.
I think what big data has done,
that is, the availability of so
much data of so many different
kinds that could be used in so
many different contexts has
created the need, as I said
earlier, to understand the full
life cycle of data, to get a
much more in depth training on
all of those aspects of data and
not just sort of stay
on the edges of it.
And I think that basically leads
to creation of data science as
an endeavor in itself.
So, I'll say maybe quite a
bit more later on about various
activities that we are
supporting and the community is
doing in pushing forward the
data science agenda but actually
a lot of what I heard this
morning, the Yale Institute for
Network Science,
is an interesting one.
There are so many common
problems with data that are seen
across so many disciplines that,
that itself becomes something
to be studied.
And we also heard that even in
something like the law school,
they would like their students
to receive at least some
training in data, so there's
also this notion that if you had
a core body of knowledge,
that information could be
imparted through specialized
courses to different other
departments and domains.
So, I think what is emerging
here is this notion of data
science and that's why I titled
my talk as Data Science R&D.
If you zoom into computer
science, as director at NSF,
we certainly found things on the
foundational research side and
the other directorates at
NSF, we, computer scientists,
think of them as the domains.
Those are the guys who have some
problems that maybe we can help
them solve it.
The Big Data program at CISE,
in CISE at NSF, is really the
one that connects the two.
So, big data, if you think in
terms of proposals, a successful
big data proposal is one
that really bridges these two
in an effective way.
It's looking at new
fundamental techniques.
Maybe it's scaling, maybe it's
a new algorithm, with a real
problem that needs to be
solved in the domain science
or engineering discipline.
So, one of the things I do in my
other life, so some of you may
have been at NSF, but if
you're at NSF there is this
notion of IRD.
You can do your independent R&D.
You get some time to do that and
one of the things I do during my
independent R&D activities
back in San Diego is related to
benchmarking of big data
applications and we run a
workshop every year and the next
one is in December in India.
And one of the speakers,
once who is from Facebook,
came and said, big data
to us means big.
Right, so if you're on Facebook,
the notion of big data,
it's just big stuff.
There's petabytes of data.
Facebook has something like
20,000-30,000 instances of MYSQL
database because every data
science with Facebook basically
goes to work every day, pulls
out some data from the big well
of petabytes of data, creates
their own little database and
they're trying the next
ad placement algorithm or
whatever it is, right.
So, there are some people for
whom big data just means big.
But what I like to say is
big data is also about data.
And the data comes from
disciplines, so if you're a
computer scientist looking
at this, there are increasingly
areas in computer science
that are sort of data
intensive... network
engineering is one.
There are groups that have
collected lots of Internet
traffic data, but by and large,
at least so far, computer
science has not been a data
intensive field but what
computer science has done is
work with data that may come
from other disciplines, and
I'm talking in terms of a field
doing its own research.
So, data has to come from
domains and, therefore,
if you're doing big data
research as a computer
scientist, you need to be very
intimately tied to the domains.
There are certainly examples
of big science data.
I won't go into all the details
of this, but I'll just give you
a laundry list of names,
many of these, many of you
would have heard of.
LIGO is a physics observatory
generating a petabyte of data
per year; LHC, Large Hadron
Collider, you've all heard about
it, it's collecting 4 petabytes
per year; LSST is the newest NSF
big instrument project that just
got inaugurated down in Chile,
I mean, the construction has
just started, and that's going
to generate 100 petabytes in
10 years, at the end of the day
it'll have a 10 petabyte catalog
database, or just a catalog of
stuff that's in the sky and the
last 10 petabytes of actually
the structured data; of course,
NCAR is an NSF funded center.
They do a lot of
observational data and they
also do simulations.
They have a new super computer
that's able to do bigger and
bigger simulations and
generate more and more data.
There are a couple of other
observational projects at NSF.
One is EarthScope in the Geo
sciences that's essentially
trying to do a 40-snapshot
of the lithospheric structure
of continental U.S.
So, they have seismograms and
other instruments that have
swept across the continent
and collected all this data.
And there's the Ocean Observing
Initiative collecting data
from ocean sites.
There are other new things
coming along the way.
You might have heard about this
interest in something called the
Materials Genome Initiative,
which is more in the chemistry
and material sciences.
That's a very nascent area.
In fact, that community is
trying to figure out what their
data challenges really are going
to be and one of the things that
they encounter is
heterogeneity of data.
Right now, the amounts of
data may not be large but they
collect all sorts of different
kinds of data and the idea here
is to see what you can do by
data collection to speed up the
materials, discover and
smart... eventually leading to
things like smart
manufacturing and so on.
All of these projects,
as I've mentioned before,
are instrumentation projects.
They get funded through the
special mechanisms that NSF has
for one-time allocation of large
chunks of money that go towards
building these things, so
these are called the MREFC,
Major Research Equipment and
Facility Construction awards.
Usually in the few hundred
million dollar range,
but I think this term
was also mentioned today.
Somebody talked
about data scope.
Maybe it was Bob,
I can't remember now.
Data, in some sense, is the new
instrument, so if I have a lot
of data available to me, like
this data scientist at Facebook
who goes to work every day
and the petabytes of stuff that
we're doing in terms of click
streams and images that we
loaded up in Facebook,
that's their data.
Increasingly, we're going to go
to a mode of operation where
just analyzing that data
is the work that you do.
So, it's not as much on the
collection side, it's more on
the analysis side.
I'm going to come back and
talk about that actually as
one of our challenges.
How do we make sure that, as
a community, we actually have
access to more and more data?
That's going to be
a bit of a challenge.
This is very quick.
I think some of you
would be very familiar.
I'm in the CAC observatories, I
think jointly run by Yale which
was up in Mauna Kea and I
was at the VLDB Conference.
I don't know if any of you had
gone there, was just a couple of
weeks ago on the big island, and
I actually went to Mauna Kea,
first time in my life,
and saw some of these.
Basically, what these
communities are facing that
increasingly all of the rest of
science is facing, is they're
able to easily collect data
which is much more than all the
data you had so far in
the history of the field.
So, in the case of astronomy,
within a decade over 140
terabytes of information was
collected so far before Sloan
Digital Sky Survey, which is
already a decade or more old,
and within the first few weeks
the Sloan Survey all took that.
LSST, in the first 10 days or so
overtakes what Sloan collected.
So, a huge rates at which
these data are being generated.
Now, if you step back and think
in terms of where we are in all
of this as an R&D discipline or
R&D activity, at the bottom what
I try to show with my funky
little diagram is, you know,
so far what we've been looking
at in the data area is building
data acquisition systems
that can collect lots of data,
building data repositories that
can serve community data sets.
Perhaps developing knowledge
structures, anthologies or
semantics of the information so
that they can be proper reuse
and use of the data.
Ideas like the data commons
so that data can be shared.
So, I can think of all of those
as sort of the infrastructure
that's around data and a lot
of what we have done so far
is in that area.
The research programs that NSF
is funding right now, in fact,
our big data program is actually
called Critical Techniques and
Technologies for Big Data,
I think are the next level up,
which is you already have these
building blocks, how do you now
build systems that allow you to
make use of data in a much more
facile and easy way, or maybe
develop new algorithms on the
data that you have?
And some of this speaks to this
idea of the human data science
interface and, I think again,
Bob mentioned that.
So, you could either the
horizontal bar, meaning that you
could build technologies that
take existing pieces and put
them together and make them
much more usable, maybe you
build workflows, etcetera.
The vertical piece meaning that
we might be inventing new ways
of doing things that we may have
to go back and change some of
what's going on
in the technologies.
So, Hadoop was mentioned
earlier, so if you look at
something like Hadoop,
people are, in a way,
reengineering Hadoop to
make it much more online.
So, when Hadoop first started
off it was kind of more for
batch oriented processing
paradigm, but people want to
process these huge amounts of
data using more of an online
paradigm, so maybe we have
to go and reengineer some
of those things.
So, that's the kind of idea.
So, I think of what's down below
and what we have done so far as
the first generation of big data
and I think where we need to be
heading is the second
generation, which is actually
the use of the data for useful
things, whether it's in science
or societal applications
or business applications.
So, it's the application of this
data towards some objective is
really the target.
So, what are the
challenges in doing this?
How do you promote and incentive
interdisciplinary research?
I think just like you folks are
doing here, I think - I don't
know if I can say all - but many
campuses are facing this issue.
How do you bring folks
together on campus?
If you really think about it,
people's life on campuses also
hurdle at light speed.
Everybody has stuff to do.
They have to publish their next
paper, graduate the next tour
and teach the next class and
then we are asking them to do
this interdisciplinary thing so
there's a challenge here and how
do you incentivize that
is one of the challenges.
One way, we think, would be
through research programs that
require you to interact.
Another challenge, as I
mentioned, and I'll be coming
back to this theme, is how do we
provide access to researchers,
to interesting and real data?
I think that's a real challenge.
It's at the crux of breaking
some of these bottlenecks and
getting more interesting
results out of data.
Again, if you think in terms of
Generation 1 and Generation 2
that I just showed, we are still
sort of in the Generation 1
where we're collecting
lots of data.
We would like to move to
Generation 2 where the
data is available.
And what you should really be
doing is using your smarts to
analyze the data and do
something interesting with it.
So, how do we get
there is a challenge.
Another challenge I see is how
do we provide the platforms,
and this is, I'm talking about
in academia, that allow you to
do data science research.
And when I say platform, I mean
the hardware, the software,
and the data.
They're all part
of the platform.
There are different parts of the
research community that might
just want a big hardware
platform so maybe they can dial
up the next hadoop or
next something, right?
There are others who want
to use the available software
to do some analysis.
One of the things I've heard
from the community certainly is
the data science, databased type
communities, a lot of papers are
published about results,
you know, how good, how fast
something runs, and there
are many such papers.
Every paper uses its own system
and these papers are really,
at some level, not compatible
because they're all running on
different hardware doing their
own, essentially, assumptions.
And so, if you really start
getting bothered by that then
you say, well, could we create
some kind of a platform on which
we can have compatible results?
And finally, the last one, which
is right now, at least to me,
seems the holy grail, is there
are researchers, at least we
would like them, to
just work with the data.
So, I give you the platform,
I give you all the software,
what I want you to do is do
something interesting with the
data and this could either
be generating new algorithms
or coming up with maybe new
science or new ways of making
decisions with the data.
So, all three are
part of the platform.
The reason this is a challenge
is, you may have heard of this,
and people are now calling
this the brain drain, right?
I've been in discussions where
there's a concern of the brain
drain, that is researchers
leaving academia to essentially
go to Google and Microsoft
and Facebook because that's -
why are they doing it?
Because that's
where the data is.
So, if you really want to
do interesting stuff with
real data, people are
moving off to those places.
Certainly, I know at UC-San
Diego we lost several of our
colleagues; one to Google, one
to Amazon, one to Microsoft.
And if you're a systems
person that's where the
big platforms are.
So, I think this is something
we need to address and how
do we do this?
So, maybe this is my chance
to do the soap box on this one.
A few decades ago the thing that
universities couldn't get their
hands on was a super computer.
The most any university could
buy a super computer like a
Cray, the one that Bob showed in
his slides, the circular thing.
So, therefore, there was a
national program that said, gee,
we'd better buy these things
and make them available
to the community.
Today, what most single
university can buy is a cluster
that Google could have,
100 or cluster.
So, how do you facilitate that?
So, this is, I have certainly
started with folks in the
community who are very
interested in at least thinking
about how to go about this
problem so maybe some of you
will pick up on that.
Education and development of
a new pedagogy in data science,
and I'll come back
and talk about that.
So, data science becomes a thing
unto itself and so how do we
develop education programs and
what are the principles of data
science as distinct from
computer science on one side
and statistics
on the other side.
Sustainability of resources,
another big problem.
So, those of you who are running
campus resources you know that
we have data management plans
but how do you keep this going?
Reproducibility of research
is another big issue, and I was
mentioning to someone,
the director of NSF just had a
seminar a couple of days ago, a
one-day workshop on this issue
of reproducibility and I
think it's a big, big deal.
If you want, we can
certainly get into discussions.
I won't say anything more about
that and I already mentioned the
brain drain issue.
So, let's see...
I'm trying to see how
I can liven this up.
Well, I guess I just
have to go through it.
This is the 30,000 foot level
thing I was talking about.
So, if you think in terms of
the investments that NSF does,
and actually, this would apply
to any federal agency that's
doing R&D investments, this is a
reasonable quadrant diagram that
we all have started
using to describe that.
So, in one box you have
foundational research; on the
other side you have
cyberinfrastructure,
the facilities; there's
education and training; and then
there's, in a way, it's
something which we call
community building and the
reason that's important in
big data is, again, because
of what we said before.
This is a field where we are
trying to connect technologies,
and I don't mean just computer
science, it's statistics, math,
CS... all of those... with end
application, real applications.
And that requires
forming collaborations.
It also requires collaborations
that are not just among academic
institutions but what we call
multi sector, so academia,
industry, and government,
and it's government at
all levels... local,
state, federal.
So, that's an important part
of trying to accelerate sort of
the whole ecosystem.
And in the middle sits policy.
Again, somebody mentioned data
policy, I think maybe in your
talk, NSF has put out a data
policy and so these are all
things that govern all of this.
So, quickly, in foundational
research, big data is a program
out of NSF.
We've just announced the awards.
I have some numbers later on.
I think we funded 30 proposals
this year in big data.
It's a cross-fitting initiative.
It involves all directorates at
NSF, it also involves an agency
called the Office of Financial
Research, and I might have
something later on that, but
Wafer was set up through the
Department of Treasury and their
task is, essentially, to build a
model of the financial system
of the country so that they
can try to do some
predictive models of where
the financial system is going.
They have access to very
interesting data and they also
have access to extremely
fine-grained financial data that
is confidential, but researchers
can get access to it in the NBA
sort of way, so it's sort of
like working with census data if
you're a demographer.
You can get micro data out
of census, but there are some
rules and regulations.
So, OFR is the same.
We also have a program called
CDS&E, Computational Data
Science & Engineering.
The distinction between these
two is in big data we are really
looking for an edge that makes
it new and different because of
the big phenomena.
Again, it's all those V's
that you saw in the slide.
You know, they have lots of
data, scaling is an issue, or if
you have lots of data maybe
simpler models work better than
more complex models, or actually
complex models won't work
because they're just too
computationally intensive.
Maybe you have a variety of
data so a lot of heterogeneity
in the data.
Maybe it's semantic
heterogeneity or some other
form of heterogeneity.
So, it has to be something in
the big data solicitation where
it's pushing a new aspect
of data, whereas in CDS&E,
the focus is more on your
pushing a new science.
You may be using a standard,
a graph method that we saw
earlier, you know, there may be
some complexity in the graph as
to what the nodes mean and what
the links mean, but what you are
really pushing is the
science that comes out of it.
So, that's sort of the
distinction between the two.
And we also have
some special programs.
Big Data for Disasters
was a program that was
done with Japan.
There's one called FutureCloud,
which is sort of a largish scale
platform, but it's much more
focused on really sort of
operating systems and network
research and not so much on the
data research itself.
And FutureCloud has been
awarded, I think there are two
platforms in the country
which are meant to
be community resources.
Cyberinfrastructure, I
think you know about this.
The ACI was mentioned before.
There is CC*DNI.
I think I heard Yale must -
you've got one of these 100
gigabyte awards to connect the
campus, so these are for high
speed networking,
building data resources,
and for HBC platforms.
I mentioned NRT on the education
side, and I'll come back to tell
you a little bit more of what
we are doing on education.
And one of the things that we
have started for the community
building is this new
program called Big Data
Regional Innovation Hubs.
Those awards were just recently
made, I believe, and I'll say
more about it, so let
me keep quiet for now.
And all of this is in the
context of all of the policy
issues that are coming out,
everything from the DMP.
You have the DMP2, to open
data policies, etcetera.
So, as I mentioned before, the
Big Data program has a focus
both on foundational research
and on innovative applications.
So, it's just a
question of the dial.
The foundational research - in
both cases you are looking for
an application that
motivates the research, but in
foundational, you are really
pushing some new techniques and
technologies, again, whether
in CS, statistics, or math.
In Innovative Applications, we
are looking for something new
being done in the science,
but also using some innovative
techniques with the data.
And, as I mentioned,
OFR is a participant.
All of this, by the way, got
started with the announcement by
the Obama Administration for
the Big Data R&D Initiative,
which was in 2012, I think,
so, 2013 was the first set
of awards, when NSF and NIH
were together at that time in
the program and that's
just a breakdown of...
I think you can sort of see,
there's purple on one side,
that's all the proposals
that we're focusing on
data collection,
management, mining,
and machine learning.
The darker one is health and bio
informatics, and then there are
other focus areas like social
networks, physical science,
engineering,
foundations, and CI.
In 2014, we had a slightly
different categorization.
There's four categories:
Data and Knowledge Analytics;
Data and Knowledge Management;
Computational Scientific
Discovery; and
Innovative Applications.
And you see the breakdown there.
There were 35 projects funded.
And the most recent one that's
just come out, and you can go to
FastLane and search and look for
big data and the current awards
we have funded.
42 proposals, which are 30
different projects and that's
because several of
them are collaborative
across multiple universities.
Most of them are actually
collaborative, at least within
the same campus, okay?
And, here's the breakdown.
63% were on the Foundational
side, 20% on the Innovative
Applications, and 17% were
a combination of the two.
And when I say foundational,
again, it's computer science,
statistics, and math, so
Stats and Math directorate is
a participant in
the big data program.
And there are 6 EAGER
grants that were also funded
as part of this.
So, the Hubs and Spokes, that's
a new program and the basic idea
here, and I won't belabor all
the details, but the basic idea
is that we see an opportunity.
I think, at the end of the day,
we are trying to push towards
how to A) bring more data out
and make it available for the
community to use in their
research; and, B) how to do this
by creating multi
sector partnerships.
So, the way the program ended
up is that we have this notion
of hubs, which are these
coordinating groups that are
meant to coordinate within
regions and we had a series of
meetings to plan this program,
and something very interesting
came up in these meetings.
The meetings were in each of the
regions, so, we have the west,
northeast, midwest, and south.
These are the four regions.
And when we had these meetings
there were a lot of universities
from those regions
as well as industry.
A lot of the discussion was
about how these people are
coming together for the first
time and one of the things we
asked in these meetings is ask
people to put up what resources
do they have available.
And all of a sudden,
the universities started
saying, oh, really?
You guys have this data?
We didn't even know
that you had that.
And industry was talking about
what kind of requirements they
have and the universities hadn't
heard from the local industry.
So, there's actually an
interesting sort of synergy
beginning to happen within the
regions and I'm actually very
hopeful that this is going to be
a very interesting mechanism by
which new ideas will come
forward and new collaborations
will come forward.
One of the things we are looking
for the Hubs to do, actually the
next program logically after
the hubs, is called the Spokes,
and right now, we are working
on the solicitation for that.
We expect, in a month or so,
maybe a couple of months,
the solicitation will come out.
As I mentioned, the Hubs were
meant to be this very high level
coordinating activities
in the region.
The Spokes are meant to have
a similar kind of diversity of
participation, but focus
on specific technical areas.
So, when the Hubs got together,
there were a lot of different
themes that came up
that they identified.
One theme that seems to be
common across the whole country
is urban science
and smart cities.
So many regions are
interested in issues related
to smart cities.
Another is global climate change
and, for example, in the west,
water was a big issue.
So, climate change and water.
In the midwest, managing the
fresh water in the Great Lakes
was a big issue.
So, there were some
common themes of this type.
And, of course, personal health
was an issue for everybody.
So, what we want the Spokes
to do, then, is to zoom into
specific areas of that type and
the Spokes will be affiliated
with the Hubs, but they
can have membership from
across the country.
They don't have to
be all members within
the particular region.
So, that's the next solicitation
that's going to be coming out.
So, the idea of the Hubs
is basically to initiate
partnerships; identify what
might be common resources in the
region, so maybe you have a
super computer, a center or
storage facility here, maybe
there's a university down the
street that would like to use
it, but they have something else
to form these kind of
collaborations; access to the
talent, both on the technology
side and the science side;
and then, shared best practices.
So, as I said, one of the things
we'd like these Hubs to do is to
start identifying datasets
that may be available and
expose this data.
Again, you already heard about
something like the NCI Commons,
which in a way, is actually
doing it for cancer data,
and I think Bob did mention it.
So, as you start doing this, you
start running into this issue of
API's and standards because
I want to share this data with
that guy, and so, what are
the standard things by which
we can do this?
NSF has funded an activity
called RDA, the Research Data
Alliance, which is trying
to do some of these kinds
of standards development.
And so, we'd like the Hubs
to play a role in not only just
trying to identify the data but
also trying to identify along
what standards can
these be made available.
And, by doing this, you know,
by the region, we hopefully
reduce the cost of, and sort of
reduce some of the duplication
that happens in these things.
So, we had these regional
meetings, as I mentioned.
The midwest folks, this
was several months ago,
they met in Ann Arbor.
The west folks actually
met in Salt Lake City.
The northeast meeting was in
Boston, but I think there's a
group at NYU that was trying to
put together the northeast Hub.
These awards have
been announced.
I think you can find them
on FastLane but they're not
yet officially announced.
And the south, the meeting was
in North Carolina and RENCI,
which is University of
North Carolina Chapel Hill
and Georgia Tech were
involved with that.
I already mentioned this.
These are some of the topics
that came up in the different
Hubs and what we found is,
it's interesting, some topics
are of interest for specific
regions, there are others that
cut across all four sectors.
So, some quick updates and
I should be done after that.
Let me talk about some
recent and upcoming activities.
There is a fifth meeting of all
the Hubs, so this would be all
the funded folks will be getting
together from November 3rd
to 5th in D.C.
Right after that, another
initiative that actually also
comes out of the White House is
trying to bring... again, this
is all in the vein of trying to
not only connect data scientists
with data, but also trying to
get more data out so that people
have access to these assets that
they can do their research.
One way we want to do
this is through a meetup
of meetup groups.
So, there are many data
science meetup groups
around the country.
There's a data science Meetup
group in San Francisco that has
a membership of 8,000.
There's one in Boston, there's
New York City, Atlanta, and the
smallest is 2,000-3,000 members.
So, if you put all of these
folks together you're talking
about something like
30,000-40,000 membership of
people who are saying they're
interested in data science.
A lot of these people are folks
who work in industry and they
want to just do data science
problems as something
that's of interest.
So, we are bringing together the
coordinators of all of these
meetup groups together in D.C.
and that's going to be right
after the Hubs meeting, so we're
trying to connect the Hubs folks
to the Meetup group folks so the
Hubs get to meet all the Meetup
groups that are in their regions
and that's another way to try
and amplify the message.
The Big Data program,
itself, will have a PI
meeting in February.
A big area that is already there
but is definitely looming in the
future, is Internet of Things,
so you expect most of the data
that's going to be coming in the
future is going to be coming
from all of these devices,
whether they're in factories or
in your house or on your body or
in your car, etcetera, right?
So, we have started a series of
workshops just focused on the
data problem with
the Internet of Things.
There are a lot
of issues with IoT.
If you just do a search on
IoT you'll see, I don't know,
maybe hundreds of
meetings and conferences.
A lot of the issues are at the
device level, at the networking
level, security,
privacy, etcetera.
We are interested on just - it's
almost like the theory of data
in the Internet of Things.
One of the issues, for example,
is the latency of data.
So, if you have an Internet of
Things, data is coming at you at
different rates
for various reasons.
The network latencies are there.
Part of the network may be down.
You might be getting good data.
You might be getting bad data.
But whatever applications are
running on top of that, they
have to make decisions and they
have to do things within some
time frame, so there's the issue
of how do you build those kind
of systems and make those
decisions in the presence of all
sorts of latency issues
and data issues?
So, we're trying
to focus on that.
We had one meeting on the
Industrial Internet, and that
was hosted by Cisco in San Jose,
and we are planning to have
a couple more.
One on Smart and Connected
Communities, and we are thinking
Chicago might be the place and
we've actually talked to the
folks who do the Internet array
of things, Charlie Catlett,
and then, of course,
personalized medicine.
Data Science and Education.
I said I was going to say
something about that.
So, that's a big, big deal and I
don't know if this is happening
at Yale, but many campuses, some
of them already have rolled out
data science programs, and
many are talking about doing
data science programs, right?
So, we had one data science
education workshop recently at
the University of Washington,
which was really exciting.
The model of that workshop was,
we funded, there was about
100 different graduate students
from different disciplines.
In fact, it was everything from
humanities and one of them was
an artist who does data based
art, you know, an outside art,
sculptures and things like this,
all the way to your usual
physical science type folks.
The whole range.
And it was really interesting
to see the dynamics
among the students.
They were just grad students
coming together and all
realizing that, you know,
they're all doing stuff for data
and many of them might be using
techniques that others could be
- you know, that you could learn
from what the others are doing.
So, it's a little bit like
what sort of happens here,
except you have 100 grad
students from all over the
country from different schools.
So, that is a very interesting
activity and I think we'll
continue that as
an annual activity.
Another workshop that I'm
planning, and we have multiple
folks at NSF involved...
the education directorate,
the statistics folks, social
science, computer science,
and also NIH... is what
we are calling Envisioning
the Data Science Discipline.
So, if you step back and think,
so what's happening right now on
a lot of campuses is people
see a market opportunity.
There's clearly a need to
produce students with a certain
set of skills, and so, they're
trying to connect the dots.
They're trying to connect the
dots from, okay, we have these
kinds of skills on campus.
We have a computer science
department, we have stats,
we have management, and we
want to produce, you know,
these kind of students,
so how do I make progress?
Which is fine.
It's a very pragmatic way to put
together a data science program.
I think we are trying to
say something different with
this Envisioning workshop.
We are trying to say, okay, if
data science was a discipline,
what would it actually look
like, and what would be the
fundamentals of data science
that make it different than
computer science and
statistics, etcetera?
It's undoubtedly an intersection
of computer science, statistics,
and social science, but it's
more of a visioning exercise.
And from that, other things
may flow, other workshops
may happen, etcetera.
And we requested the
National Academy of Science
to run this workshop,
so that's coming up.
If you have thoughts or
interests let me know.
We already have a list
of folks that we'd like to
invite to this.
And as you may or may not, that
every directorate at NSF has an
advisory committee, which is
essentially the folks from the
community who provide advice to
the directorate at NSF, and CISE
has an advisory committee and we
just now set up a subcommittee
of that focused on
data science education.
And so, again, they are also
looking at, you know, more from
a computer science point of
view, what should we be doing,
what should we be teaching, what
are the facilities that need to
be in place to teach data
science effectively, and so on?
Last couple of slides.
So, I did say that there is
interagency activity going on,
so, one of my jobs at
NSF is to actually co-chair
this interagency group.
We just call it the Big Data
Senior Steering Group,
which was actually set
up as part of the original
Obama Administration Initiative.
The group is co-chaired
by NSF and NIH.
So, it includes over 18
different federal R&D agencies
who are all interested in
big data, so it's the usual.
You know, we have NASA,
NOAA, DOD, DOE...
Department of Energy,
NSA and NIST and so on.
These are just informational.
So, that's going on and actually
we have monthly meetings, and we
actually invite external
speakers to come and speak and
I think there's an invitation
out to Bob and the NOAA folks to
come and talk about the NOAA
Cloud that they went through.
Another activity going on is the
NIST Public Working Group on Big
Data, which is actually
trying to develop standards,
and actually I was
a co-chair of that.
I have to say. I'm a
non-active co-chair right now.
I think one of the things that
happens in government is once
your name is there, it's
actually hard to remove it.
But, it's been interesting to
observe that because the field
is moving so fast that every
time they get down to defining
something it's moved along
and keeping up is very hard.
So, we do collaborate with NIH.
There is a program that NSF
recently announced with the
Statistics Institution and NIH
called Quantitative Approaches
to Biomedical Big Data.
Is anyone from Yale
participating in that,
do you know?
Okay.
They have funded a number
of planning grants, I believe,
and this is, again, NIH
interested in connecting with
the statistics community to see
what kind of statistical methods
could be used for the
kinds of big data that they
have in biomedicine.
And I was mentioning to someone
earlier today, in fact, had a
meeting with NIH, Phil Bourne,
who was your speaker last year.
Phil and I have been talking
along with some folks at NSF
about doing a workshop, and this
one will be in conjunction with
the UK Research Councils
on how to try and expose more
biomedical data for the
community to do research on.
So, the UK folks have, you know,
good datasets, I think because
of their national health
service and so on.
Increasingly, NIH is trying
to put out more datasets.
There's something called
healthdata.gov you might be
familiar with, where
agencies are trying to
publish health data.
And so, it's going to
be an NSF-funded workshop.
We'll actually run it at NIH and
we'll have participation from
the UK Research
Councils on that.
So, my last slide is some
set of things where we
need your inputs.
So, this, I think,
is a real challenge.
How do we get our hands on data?
So, we need your ideas.
We need to release more data.
We need to put it out there and,
as you know, it's not just,
I mean, the data has to sit next
to computing, right, so it could
be a hadoop style or whatever
the style or platform is,
but computing has to be there
with the data, so it's not just
publishing files on an FTB
site or something like this.
How do we build
platforms at scale?
As I said, I've actually started
a conversation with some of the
folks in the community,
and this is more the computer
science folks, as to
how would we do this?
And, especially in an
environment where, and as far as
I'm concerned the country
doesn't care for R&D, right?
If you sit at NSF, somebody
said the other day, in fact,
our assistant director,
said Flat is the new Positive,
or something like that.
If you are flat
you will be happy.
If your budgets are flat
it's supposed to be happy.
And our budgets are flat.
And I was at this workshop at
the University of Washington,
one of the faculty said, you
know, NSF doesn't understand
that there is
inflation in this world.
And, by the way, I
was a PI till a year ago.
I was on the same
side a year ago.
It's thought that NSF
doesn't understand.
NSF budgets are flat.
You know, if you guys keep
getting 2% or 3% raises
or even higher.
Private schools probably
give you lots of big raises -
University of California
doesn't give huge raises.
Sorry.
That means, you know, you're
going to put less effort on a
project because the
amount of money is fixed.
So, if you want to fix that I
think you need to go and talk to
people in Washington, D.C.
So, that's my pitch.
Okay.
So, we're in the day of flat
budgets but we want to have
these new initiatives, you know,
we want to create new big data
platforms, and I mean, you can
imagine back to the day, 20-30
years ago, when somebody said,
and this was Sid Karin and
Larry Smarr, that we
need super computers.
We need super computer centers
and new money materialized at
NSF to fund super
computers, okay?
This is what we need today.
We need big data platforms
but how do we make it happen,
so we need your help.
Another issue, and I think some
of you may be involved with it,
but I know there are other
research folks very much in this
area of data ownership.
You know, who owns the data,
including, in today's world,
what's happening to
all of us right now.
Somebody, again, Bob.
All these references
are going back to Bob.
I think you mentioned something
about do you know where
your data is.
So, there's this issue of how do
we tackle that problem, right?
It's not just the issue of
keeping data anonymized and
private and giving protected
access but it's also who's
the controlling power?
You know, who's ruling
in this case?
And the last thing I'll say,
we actually fund a group,
and it's a multi university,
but I think based out of NYU,
and other folks.
There's folks from UC Irvine,
maybe Johns Hopkins.
I can't remember
all the schools.
I can't remember if Yale is
there on it, but it's called
Big Data Ethics and Society.
So, I talked about
data science education.
I mean, I really think that
data science has three legs.
It's computer science,
statistics, and social science,
especially the ethics part.
The biggest Achilles heel for
data science is going to be on
the ethics side because the
first time somebody, not that
it's already not happened
already, but, you know,
the first time someone goes and
messes up data it's going to
be a huge, huge issue.
So, I think of ethics as a
very big topic and so, again,
whatever ideas you have,
the more you can teach it,
the more you can
do in it it's great.
As I said, we fund this group
called Big Data Ethics and
Society and we've asked them
to come and present at the
Big Data PI's meeting.
We may also ask them to attend
the Hubs meeting so that they
can sort of - it's a very good
group of folks and hopefully
they can spread this message.
So, if you have folks on this
campus interested in the ethics
issue I think they should
really get connected to this.
So, I apologize for
such a dry talk.
I didn't realize it was going
to be this dry, but it's very
interesting to me.
So.
(Applause)
So, I also did not
find that dry at all.
I thought it very interesting.
Thank you.
So, Yale is actually a part of
the northeast regional big data
hub along with Columbia, and we
currently have three faculty
that are helping
drive that initiative.
Can you speak a little bit about
the skill sets for the other
folks that will be needed to
help support and propel that
initiative should the
funding be received?
Okay.
So, that's a very good question.
I think I had, at the bottom of
that slide, something about the
Hugs are there to enable
you to do something that
you couldn't otherwise
do by yourself, that is.
And when I say you,
it's even the campus.
So, it's really regional in that
sense, so I'm not sure what all
the issues here are, but I know
about water in San Diego,
so let me pick water in
California as an issue.
So, if you want to try and
address the water issue in
California, you need
partnerships across the state,
both in academia
and also agencies.
So, I think the kind of folks
you need to be involved,
the Hubs program is very
different than what NSF
has done before.
It's almost like an altruistic -
well, it's an organizational
thing, but it's also altruistic,
so PI's are not very good at
being altruistic, right?
I mean, I've been a PI, so PI's
are all about, okay what's in
the budget for me?
But here, we are talking about
how do you bring together all
sorts of different actors to
create a more complete picture
of whatever it is that
you're trying to solve.
So, if you can get faculty
who are interested in that.
Well, one of the things
I find, especially in the
interdisciplinary work,
including I've met some recent
young faculty at UCSD, is that
the young faculty have a lot of
energy in this interdisciplinary
stuff, but I'm not sure if Hubs
is where you'd want
to engage them.
If you can find that senior
faculty, maybe Bob, but Bob is
not so senior, but, anyway,
if you can find the experienced
faculty who is also interested
in doing something that's
broader than just their own
program, those would be the
right kind of people.
And obviously, that means they
have to have an interest that's,
you know, we're using -
and you'll see it in the
solicitation as well, we use the
term National Priority Areas,
so the White House OSTP has
announced a number of priority
areas... precision medicine
is one, global climate change
is one, smart manufacturing,
smart interconnected
communities... these
are all considered to
be priority areas.
So, if you have folks who are
interested in working in those
priority areas, but not so
narrowly interested in just
their own lab but actually
trying to reach out and help,
and I'm sure there
are many here.
I certainly know folks at
other places who are like that.
Those would be the
best folks to engage.
Is this model being extended
to other parts of the world?
Good question.
So, actually, in the Spokes
solicitation, which we are right
now working on putting it
together, we received interest
from international groups who
want to participate in this.
So, the Hubs didn't say, but the
Spokes will actually say that we
encourage international
partnerships, and so,
there could be some topics.
Actually, smart cities is a good
one, right, because there's a
faculty member at MIT
who visited Singapore.
Singapore has a vague smart
city initiative and what they
realized is because of the way
everything gets controlled in
Singapore, I suppose, they can
control how data is released.
And they realized that the data
that they have is actually an
asset for international
collaborations because not many
cities or states have
that kind of data that they
have access to.
So, for example, in Smart and
Connected Cities, we have a
connection with Singapore
and we can get all their data
and we can do some
very fancy, you know,
parking optimization
or whatever.
That would be interesting.
So, I think the
Spokes will ask for
encourage international
partnerships.
We are also finding a lot of
interest from other agencies.
I'm not sure of the solicitation
with the state or not, but some
of the agencies are even saying
that they may do their own
solicitation which, in some
ways, is actually simpler,
but then connect to the Hubs.
So, you know, DHS is also very
interested in Smart City issues,
and actually, I mentioned the
Internet of Things workshop,
I don't think I mentioned the
next series of workshops we are
doing is with NHS, so
it'll be NSF-DHS jointly
doing IoT workshops.
I won't be surprised if someone
like that will put something out
and say, you know, we have an
opportunity here and we would
like to connect this
to the NSF Hubs.
Thank you for your talk.
Something you said I thought was
interesting, or it was on your
slide, is that you said data is
a new instrument, and I'm coming
from a bioinformatics
background and when I think of
bioinformatics compared
to traditional life sciences
I think of instead of
studying living things,
I'm studying the data.
I'm serving the data and the
metadata on the data, but I
usually think of the instruments
that I'm using as mathematics,
statistics, and
computer science.
So, I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about how you
see data as the actual
instrument instead of the
thing being measured.
Right.
And, you know...
I think what I really mean
there is, there's a lot of
opportunity, and I think in
astronomy this has already being
done, where you can
discover new things just by
analyzing the data.
So, you don't have to go
to the instrument like a
telescope or something.
Of course, somebody went and
brought it together, the data
could just be click streams and
maybe you observe some social
phenomena by observing
something in the click stream.
That's kind of what I mean.
So, it's an instrument to study
a phenomena in that sense.
Can you join me in
thanking our speaker?
(Applause)